[Music]
welcome back to careful boys careful be
careful please we got silent mike over
here everybody oh a reckless boy
so i saw this meme uh
so kyrie irving for my non-sports fans
uh really good point guard in the league
probably maybe top five you can argue
whatever what teams he plays right now
he plays on brooklyn uh the meme though
and i'll tell you i'll explain the meme
after we're gonna go meme and then we'll
explain
understand
uh yeah yeah there was a meme that said
uh brooklyn that's just silent assigned
uh kyle irving and his dude's got white
hair and glasses he said uh he said he
loves vaccines in the world's rounds
so this dude kyrie irving this dude
kyrie irving uh baller dude you don't
typically think about this in the nba
but uh there's big coveted stuff going
on and protocols are changing protocols
are our country's [ __ ] dude
everything's so different
everything's different by state so he
plays in brooklyn right we're right next
to new york and their rules are way more
strict so i think they're making every
and maybe it's the nba don't write i
think it's this i think it's the state i
think so too new york just new york's
making every single brooklyn player get
vaccinated yeah right mandatory
vaccinations because because of the
state or the city or depends on it's
pretty sure it's the state i think i
think this one in particular is the city
even though right oh yeah because i
think the the knicks have to also yeah
it is city actually so kyrie irving says
no and then like what three years ago or
something he was uh getting an interview
about he's a flat earther
kyrie is an odd guy though i never knew
that because he went to duke he kind of
had the typical nba path yeah is it
because when he sees the hardwood floor
he's like it's flat bro
my balls are bouncing straight up
there's videos of him walking around the
court before the game with sage
lighting on fire so i like that no no no
now you're insulting me no no you know
who did that first who phil jackson the
most yeah he's the guy ever when they
no i think it's a a little bit because
my mom does it but my mom's kind of
weird my mom i thought that was a nice i
think it's a native american one i think
i think it's all the above bro i think
everybody [ __ ] with bernie sanders and
it's just like a ritualistic like i'm
gonna get another song clear bad spirits
but people were making fun of him like i
don't i don't care i say [ __ ] it my wife
does all the time in the house oh really
is she catholic yeah i think it's
catholic but i think it's also a pagan
witchcraft deal i think i'm sure it's
just nice dude half of the [ __ ] [ __ ]
in the in the from the church is like
all the paganism stuff
according to google yeah where'd the
sage come from uh the practice
originates as an ancient spiritual
ritual called smudging as well and has
been well established as a native
american cultural or tribal practice
although it isn't practiced by all
groups yeah it feels like groups phil
jackson here and losing streaks would
walk the entire arena they said yeah the
entire home arena and just just [ __ ]
stage that [ __ ] where did the [ __ ] out
he's a winner dude he's like the
greatest coach of all time
maybe it works maybe belichick's doing
that [ __ ] in the locker room
on all the footballs hey maybe we need
to sage this [ __ ] up and then
we'll finally hit 2 million subscribers
we've been at 1.81.9 for [ __ ] like
this because we don't [ __ ] with the sage
dude juju bro we need a re-cleansing i
gotta over something yeah bring some
[ __ ] sage man this is a new patreon
segment yeah
we need to wear our birthstones and [ __ ]
too they made fun of they made fun they
made fun of it and then but it was also
in line with like there were memes with
him with the sage and then him talking
about flat earth but the flat earth
stuff is like come on kyrie but the main
thing now is he's saying he doesn't want
to get vaccinated right that's like the
main thing why he's in the yeah yeah
what's what's that about he's not gonna
he's not gonna play he's just getting
suspended yeah he doesn't get uh well so
the weird part if you guys wanna get
like a pseudo political about it the
weird part is new york or the city can't
make incoming players right there's
obviously two teams [ __ ] playing they
can't make it
yeah yeah like oh that doesn't really
work like yeah the entire brooklyn teams
but the lakers show up and none of them
are vaccinated they're just tested like
what's the point here yeah correct right
right i'm not dumb right like most of
the cobot protocols that's really stupid
as well yeah what's the what's the
option he gets drafted somewhere else no
no no no no no uh they hold them they
could trade them but no way they're
gonna trade there won't because uh
basically if he doesn't play i don't
think you get paid a lot of your bonuses
so he just won't play literally won't
play or maybe he'll only travel i don't
even know hey dude i like being on a
plane okay and then oh thank you
stewardess very much
and then
[Music]
[Laughter]
just [ __ ] off
like
you guys see elon tweet about that
recently he's like he's like yeah i like
being on a plane and then you know i
order a soda and then like i could take
my mask off he's like i love following
the science
i love
when i was on the airplane when i came
back from hawaii i made my soda last the
whole yeah yeah i've seen fools on the
plane like
jerky like for four hours just hanging
on the ear yeah hey what's up kai
what's up guys dude i like walking
around outside and there's some lady you
know walking her dog or whatever and
she's got her mask down and then all of
a sudden i'm walking by and she's like
we're i'm like we're outside have you
ever seen the vapor actually dissipate
from your mouth with wind like you don't
know what the [ __ ] is going on part of
it is like oh that you know i get it
she's in her mind she's trying to be
nice and trying to be like thoughtful
but also just stay six feet away from me
that's it yeah yeah opposite side of the
road you don't gotta wear masks i see
old ladies i appreciate the old lady
that would do that i would [ __ ] hold
my breath because they stink you know i
feel bad for i walk through the
neighborhood where i live sometimes and
they're just old ladies like watering
their lawns and they just put their
masks on they're by themselves by
themselves nowhere near us
and there's water in the lines and i'm
like man i wish she would just take it
off a little bit hey dude calm down
she's you know take it off take it off
leave the mask on blouse off dude that's
what i'm talking about you're probably
doing it because you would look like
coronavirus yourself dude
i know she's like this [ __ ]
corona virus dude i haven't seen that
with me and steve
never happened
except for the people who died for their
masks when i'm walking by they're
[ __ ] diving for it like okay like
what the [ __ ] do you think they run away
right and they're cutting the hair you
got to keep the mask on
and then
when it gets to like the sideburns or
whatever they take it they go can you
take it off so i take it off
and then i go can i just leave it off
then because i've already have it off
for five minutes
and then he goes i can't because it's
the law and i'm like i know
i feel like barber shops nobody wears
massive barber shops all the barbershops
i've been to nobody where's my not me
buddy don't burn them out
double masks
like there's cigarette smoke [ __ ]
everywhere i feel like i'm in a marlboro
pack it's so strong that my [ __ ] mask
i'm smoking do they smoke through the
mask i don't know but then everyone's
masked out they cut holes in it they're
mashed up pretty hard you went yeah
literally what three days ago yeah they
were masked up pretty hard there i
thought they took it out no
they are i don't know the rule i don't
know what the city or whatever but
people are doing it yeah i literally
when we're in vegas i put my mask on
because of the cigarette smoke i feel
like a hell of it yeah i feel like it
helped a little bit because we were
either we had our mask on walking around
somewhere and some chick walked by me
and you know your perfume is way too
[ __ ] strong when that smells
normal through my mouth go through an
n95 yeah yeah yeah i know i had this guy
the [ __ ] gas mask when she put it on
she put this on she's like yeah i can't
show you she smell it what the [ __ ] yeah
she was going nuts i kind of like how
the mask is like normal though now in
the u.s like before kovid they would
they'll be like that's [ __ ] i just
don't like it in the gym
you're all training you know i don't
want to do it there but like if you want
to just just be out in public and [ __ ]
because you don't want to smell people
or whatever like you won't look weird
anymore i just feel like six feet solves
all that that's what i'm a big proponent
of that just stay away from me bro it's
it's really great too when they have uh
you're at the grocery store and like
every other
la aisle is closed
right but then you're standing with
everyone in the row and it's all packed
because there's less lanes and there's
nobody doing the six feet thing
same with the airplane deal like i'm
sitting on your [ __ ] lap because he
sees your [ __ ] and this mask is why do
we solve the bigger issue here well i'm
very uncomfortable hey how about we're
all going to the same bathroom yeah yeah
like exactly asked to have a mask yeah
and then when i go to the bathroom i
have to walk by everyone in the whole
[ __ ] plane right
this [ __ ] is hilarious dude it is tough
don aren't they saying that the uh
the countries that have the most
vaccinations are also the countries that
have the most new kobe cases yeah israel
is one of them right now yeah it's crazy
because a delta variant don't give a
[ __ ] about your vaccination that's why
but each country does have a different
vaccine well for the most part right a
lot of it is we bought all certain
brands yeah
a lot of it is the same pharmaceuticals
though like it's the same formula
that the license or whatever they do
yeah what about your boy who a-rod oh
a-rod you guys hear about this yes uh
yeah yeah yeah my boy he's my boy i love
aaron rodgers dude i don't give a [ __ ]
how did you he's a norcal guy i love
aaron rodgers he got he got suspended
from the nfl football player football
quarterback one of the most iconic
quarterbacks of all time yeah this
[ __ ] i guess he lied about
having a vaccination
and then he got coveted
and then they suspended him did they
find both
he said i'm immunized he didn't say i
don't i got the vaccination yeah maybe
he got chickenpox yeah right yeah well
well maybe he had covenant and he has
the community yeah natural media he said
i've been immunized but that made people
believe that he had the vaccinations
so that's what it was because that was
my biggest that was my biggest question
was like how did you fake having a vet
well what's weird is that even if you
have the vaccine you could still get it
right that's why i wondered how this
happened yeah
yeah why do they why do people act like
getting the vaccine is like now you're
[ __ ] protected but doesn't it curb
the symptoms isn't that the whole point
of it
it's supposed to be severe yeah but you
could still get it or the vaccine would
have really worked if everyone got
vaccinated at the same time i had so
appointed i had covered twice too right
and i'm i have the antibodies and my
second time was a [ __ ] cakewalk i
have a fat old dick though i got a big i
got a big old cocktail that's that's a
little vitamin or something what did i
have to do with it
that's a study brother new paper came
out dude today's video is brought to you
by hellofresh you might be wondering
what in the world is a hellofresh with
hellofresh you get fresh this is very
very fresh
pre-portions pre-packaged ingredients
straight to your doorstep so you could
assemble this real quick easy to do at
your own home and that's probably one of
my favorite parts of it because in this
day and age there's a lot of kids that
look at a dinosaur on a plate and they
don't know that it's chicken or where
chicken comes from and when we cook with
the family taika gets to see all of the
ingredients come together he gets to see
that the carrots and the potatoes and
this goes into this so when he actually
makes the meals
and when we make the meals as a family
he actually appreciates what he's eating
way more it doesn't go to waste and also
the holidays they can be crazy hectic
you know like especially a person like
me
i got so many places to be
so many places to cook for i don't know
what the hell to do anymore especially
people are like yo can you come over to
my house and this and
you know i don't know what to do but
thank goodness hello fresh they have
everything packaged ready to go takes
the thinking out for me i just choose
what types of dishes i want comes over
boom and i don't feel guilty because i
don't have all these freaking groceries
just all up in my refrigerator i live
alone and i'm like what am i gonna do
with all this food
i it's gonna go rotten i just want one
half of a lemon what the heck man
another cool thing is hellofresh has
flexibility so like you don't have to be
stuck to whatever you choose where it's
like i ordered food every single day or
whatever it's a flexible plan you could
get like three meals a week whatever
works for you so if you want to try
america's number one meal kit
go check out hellofresh.com
off the record 14 to get 14 free meals
plus three free gifts free
free that's a ton of meals you could try
for free and they got everything from
italian to asian to vegetarian there's
no reason why you shouldn't try it
especially people that are kind of
intimidated by cooking it's a really
good way to get into it even taika can
do it go to hellofresh.com
off the record 14 to get 14 free meals
plus three free gifts thank you very
much guys is that why i had such a tough
time
it's like a swollen lip balm
but my first time was rough my first
time was absolutely wrong dick grew in
between the two but my
my big old [ __ ] is what's a man though
the second time around dude no no but
like yeah that's what i heard that's all
obviously having the antibodies is good
or having the vaccination is good if you
never had kova but if you had covet
having the the antibodies is the best
thing you could have right now what
about the dick port how do i get that
uh you gotta take rhino pills from the
gas station dude in the uk in the uk you
could get it
and basically it's like just as good as
a vaccine card so the card lasts about
two to three months or something if you
have natural immunity yeah if you just
got covered the doctor goes oh you
probably you know you're gonna have
immunity so it's like an immune immunity
or whatever just like a proof of proof
of immunity
mutination card or whatever yeah
communications look at that
i'm just oh yeah but you can't have that
here though like you still need to get
the vaccinations got too much money and
big fun well they're so they're so this
is what i think what happened right i
think they gave it to us real madrid i
think they bit off more than they can
chew meaning that the government made a
sweet deal with the pharmaceuticals and
they
bought so [ __ ] much inventory that
they need to unload this or they look
like buffoons and i never sell us out
the big pharma because right now
you know what's crazy is they're trying
to [ __ ] um show this out to children
right now yeah so that's 211.
you know what's crazy is like they're so
uptight about like um licenses or credit
cards right numbers like our whole
world's based on these bar codes and
stuff i went to an nba game and uh you
show your card to get in either a test
or your card and i'll show my card and
she's like yeah next time just take a
picture of it with your cell phone and i
can just kind of go by that i was like
you can go buy a blurry ass picture on
my smudge phone of a of a piece of paper
that's not even laminated okay seems
secure
and that's all safe like when we go to
hawaii they have to show you have to
upload your vaccination card and stuff
but then sometimes you hear these
stories about how you upload to a system
and you take a picture of it and then
you upload it but then there's people
that get popped for having fake
vaccinations oh yeah there was a father
and son that got [ __ ] in that pocket
but then my whole thing is like how do
you get popped for that then like how do
you how do you pop for fake vaccination
cards like what's the crosstalk like
your qr code doesn't work or your card
ain't even a qr code do you have a card
yeah my card is just like a one i lost
my card but i have a qr code hey
literally i'm looking at this
you're in the system oh yeah i think
you're right it is computerized yeah
yeah i think you're in the system my
card itself is trash yeah i lost it i
don't have my card mine looks like a
froyo punch card
that's what it looks like literal your
fourth vaccine is free
it's going to get there no it's we're
there yeah cause like my dad's getting
the booster this week have you gotten
your eighth booster yet yeah over there
i'm trying to they were giving out free
uh laker tickets for like people
incentivizing people in la to get the
too i wanna i was like i'll take another
shot bro giving out free laker tickets
yeah dude like like like you get put in
a raffle you gotta put in a raffle no i
think you didn't didn't new some do like
a meal the whole state did like a
million dollars i think no it was a
raffle though right
giving out free donuts if you have a
vaccine that's fine
i'm cool with that yeah yeah free donuts
is awesome
fake vaccine cards no see i was gonna
dig into that i'm gonna i'm gonna go
against you oh yes we go because like uh
the the fitness industry was up in an
uproar because they're all like all we
talk about is dax and we never talk
about how fat we are i'm like yeah
that's obviously an issue but that's
that's like straw man argument right
that makes no sense and then they got
real mad that krispy kreme was giving
out a donut when he got a vaccine and
i'm thinking like oh no they're
winchell's guys yeah well i'm like
what about that what about donkeys uh my
argument though is like all these fat
[ __ ] never got fat off one
donut i know right they're good those
[ __ ] are not excited by one
free donut they wanted a dozen yeah
that's not getting them back
don't demonize the food it's not the
food that's wrong it's like over
consumption is what's happening it's
free who's complaining about it give me
a [ __ ] doughnut yeah i'll take a
doughnut 200 calories this is the cream
filled too extraordinary doughnuts is
that yeah sounds like don't they don't
you want to complain if someone offered
a scoop of rice you know it's the same
[ __ ] right yeah that's racist you're
gonna get a vaccine for a scoop of rice
no [ __ ] for the coven facts i don't
know we're getting weird dude i might do
it for i might do it for a whole bag of
green rice that i have to cook myself me
and steve
box of bags
mac and cheese
boston market oh man dude there's a lot
of police departments in like uh cities
too new york mandating
vaccines that's what's crazy there's a
lot of cops just walking out and city
officials just walking out yeah i don't
know particularly again i think it was
firefighters and and police did because
you know what's crazy right it's like
okay when you know babies get their
shots like they get what means like what
do they what what do you know
right so that's
yeah it makes sense there was a huge
plague it would [ __ ] people up sure
whatever right
um but then um
you know it's still a choice
like you you can still not get those
shots it's on you and if you don't
anti-vaxx models
and then if your kid you know in
disneyland they got the [ __ ] black
plague or whatever because the kids
didn't get the shots and then they died
right yeah but it's at the end of the
day it's the choice of you right
so
even if your vaccine if they're saying
that oh it's for other people though
when you're vaccinated it's not for you
well
they're wrong because you still can get
coveted if you're vaccinated so it's not
for other people so what's the whole
point is what i'm thinking about is like
what's the whole mandate behind it
because we're not mandated to get other
vaccinations i don't think all vaccines
eliminate disease yeah all vaccines uh
the percentage changes some are more uh
effective than the coven ones are
currently but because they're like 60
years old we already like bypassed that
all i know is that the polio didn't just
eliminate polio the next day no no no
yeah yeah funneled it down right and
we're just at the tip of the funnel
because we're a new generation so you're
talking about herd immunity with the
with the with the vaccinations which
from like what the polio one like let's
say i get that polio vaccine right if
nick has a polio we start [ __ ] you
could get you could i could you could
yeah so you better watch out 100 none of
it
all i know is that i'm gonna give you
polio real good you have to get a polio
booster every year every single year you
better make sure you get it
it's important so you're saying that
one generation cycle from now
these well i'm not a [ __ ] doctor
don't come at me like i'm fouchy and i'm
gonna get quoted everywhere i don't know
[ __ ] i don't know [ __ ] but i do know but
that's the whole mindset behind
vaccinations right right that none of
them are a hundred percent effective but
if enough people do it enough
generations do it and we slowly
eliminate that so we're saying is
because we're america it's not gonna
work for a long time especially in our
culture yeah see because we just said
that israel is having more breakthrough
cases than anywhere and they're the most
vaccinated it's not the best vacs and
that's the problem we've gotta let the
dust settle i didn't do the research but
the middle of all this chaos it was like
in south lake tahoe or tahoe which is
right by me there was a small plague
outbreak swearing plague like [ __ ]
black plague
like a bubonic that kind of plague
they're still around like again they
didn't just totally eliminate [ __ ] and
also like hit china again once slash
yeah see like they can they can figure
it out and save it and we have more
science to kind of fix it but like i've
read that in the thing i'm like i'm
never reading the news again bro like
come out it still exists yeah yeah
there's medieval [ __ ] walking
around and [ __ ] yeah it was a night yeah
it was king arthur there was a bunch of
kids that got the black plague at
disneyland dude yeah because the [ __ ]
girl
backs kids
[Laughter]
that's how good their fans they're on
the [ __ ] teacup ride dude
that makes sense art direction for real
over there the earth's actually flat
could have been medieval times as well
could have been it was the water from
the small world man no for sure was the
water or the one from the small flat
world yeah the small world island and
[ __ ] have you seen the water in there
it's disgusting no oh wait where people
are canoeing that shit's great yeah
that's where they got it they got it
from canoeing that's where coven started
who goes to disneyland because really
get the vaccine yo i go there so i could
play in the playground at the
huggleberry island but you don't do the
canoeing that's awesome that's stupid
have you guys ever done that disneyland
it was regretful uh the only reason i
want to i'm kind of a nerd uh i think
back up in that [ __ ] is you can get like
a a private like cabin
no [ __ ]
yeah i think yeah but if you do the
canoeing you don't go there i don't know
it's just you might be able to see it no
for sure but then i would like to do it
like hop in my canoe and then go to my
sick vip cabin
mistake like i might be mistaken but
there was a guy who swam across the
huckel ferry huckleberry finn island or
something and he died i don't know no
last year the year before the exact
hotel i stayed at i went out to a
wedding with my moms and the family and
we stayed at a hotel and then we did the
disney thing after the
disney hotel one of them one of it
because they have like a billion in yeah
was it the one oh it's florida oh
there's a kid that got eaten by a
crocodile i was on that beach bro
like like a month before
a little baby i think it was a baby
literally just got snatched up by
crocodile eight and then i heard they
went out there and just shot guns like a
hundred gators to find them [ __ ] they're
like this ain't happening again it was
just revenge let's do see i respect that
yeah yeah kill all the crops and then
all you buy is disney uh gator boots
florida
[Music]
you